hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play the mental
hospital now this is about as new as an
indie game can come it was released on
the 6th of December and it is now the I
don't know of December I don't know what
day it is so I'm gonna give it a try
there's only a few people that have
played it so far and so there's not a
lot of word out about if it's good or
not but I'm gonna give it an honest try
here we go and receive now that sounds
familiar
haha if I'm not mistaken that's the
exact music from SCP OMB oh that's a
press F oh okay I mean I'm in the game
already whoops oh nevermind Oh a gun I
like it
mrow three of zero anything else is
wrong just uh no bed in a strange toilet
okay oh well this game seems to have the
atmosphere down pat I applaud that holy
crap
hahaha holy crap oh god those doors I
don't like those doors what's that sound
sounds like wind or a bad musical
instrumental of course I don't like this
place
holy crap it is holy crap oh sure
you hear that did anybody hear that wha
what was that I saw so like a doll on
that dresser and then things moved oh
why
what no don't close that I want to get
out oh my god I hear that challah crap
this is like the most atmospheric game
I've ever played in my life it is so
unbelievably dark and Oh God as those
are if you guys can't see anything but I
got
ah ding ding ding ding oh man holy ball
arena aha I'm okay
I think he's just throwing things at me
and they're not actually gonna get me so
I'm okay
oh look it's like it's light down there
ha ha ha
those light the light there was light
for a fraction of a second there was
light no huh oh it's just TVs ah
oh that's all behind me you dick
oh shut up I don't want to go I'm not
gonna help you you dick I can't see
anything oh I know there are mannequins
out there oh it really is someone in
here or there's not there's probably not
that's probably huh
I'm not gonna help you bro hyah I don't
want to help you
Oh God other things out here who's this
Oh Oh aah sorry bro
ah my bad I was Isis there's still
people here and there's mannequins
standing out there and you're already
dead
I think not poof ha if I was already
dead I would have nothing to worry about
because I'm very afraid of being dead
what why why why was that gurney rolling
why can't I have some ding-dong damn
light
the bathtub good good
ha it's that doll that's it all her eyes
are that's what I saw
are you were you were you huh
why worry oh god why is it bloody where
your head ugh
ok the music just started back up again
ok that's ok that's ok
I dealt with that music before uh-huh Oh
God ah I got my gun out I'm gonna shoot
anything that comes through that door
I'm gonna shoot all about a shoe you so
dead cheeky so dad uh
I can't see oh good whoa okay who's that
hey gurney Thank You Bree
oh god no no I'm not going downstairs
after that that's not an F you squeeze
Oh what's it a light switch that don't
work oh oh damn it
is that wait what oh I don't like that
daddy ass dear what could they possibly
mean [ __ ] Tia oh why what uh what what
the hell that's not the ceiling thing
disappeared for saying hey I check every
room on this floor before I venture down
clothes clothes or clothes clothes
clothes clothes are clothes why which
word damn English
oh no no is something nearby I guess I'm
going downstairs now
oh man oh man oh no no no no come on
think of ponies Oh babies
you know kittens little puppies happy
thoughts happy thoughts
Oh sad thoughts
oh my god I can't see can't go look at
the floor
what is it was it is it okay cool
who your bathroom man oh they're not
gonna last but not gonna last
wha Oh sis agree there's nothing in
there I run so slowly haha I'm ready I
can't write oh yeah no oh you bastards
oh you mother oh you mother shut up man
we all got problems
okay I can't get through there good I
wanna go there anyway oh god it's
horrible it's like every single room
there's something that happens I'm not
even good only I'm not going in the
bathroom I don't think there was
anything else in that bathroom but I'm
going back in it cuz f that and F F
everything about that was just a little
bottom level
wait hang on I gotta check under the
stairs nothing just a pride shut up man
what is that what is that hanging in the
middle there what is that oh it's a pipe
or it's the edge of the water the door
hanging off its hinges
oh god I gotta I wanna back out what a
shot
oh no always suitable it oh shut up
those any different language that can
read that oh god oh god oh god no no no
is this what is this what is this what
is this what is this button bunch
ahahaha shut up shut up oh god what is
the puddings game I seat beam easy
coming in again I'm pretty sure that
music didn't originate with se piece by
some royalty-free music that everybody
can use so you know I won't faulted for
oh my god my ammo counter went away okay
yay okay Gawker Oh
Wow
I'm done I fancy an that not the end
bomb done cuz f this game and F
everything about it cuz only Paul Reno I
I don't even even know where to begin
with this game it's holy crap
this gotta be the scariest game I've
ever played
maybe may I don't know I don't know I I
don't know I'm just like I couldn't take
it I don't even know what happened there
why I lost I don't know
but frankly I don't care cuz I'm done
I'm done with that that is I'm not gonna
go through that again
not today anyway so hah men legs in the
description below if you want to torture
yourself and play this game man kudos to
the maker Oh God
oh alright so anyway thank you guys so
much for watching click the and take
some more videos that I've done and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
oh god damn it